[Musique]
quelques consignes très importantes
notamment au niveau de la sécurité on va
évoluer en fil
indienne
[Musique]
le but de cette journée c'est c'est pour
l'écologie c'est pour que Ben comme tout
le monde parte en voiture en travail que
ils peuvent aussi prendre des vélos ça
ça gaspill ça va gaspiller moins
d'essence et sera bon pour
l'environnement ça va moins polluer ce
sera mieux pour notre santé là
maintenant on va ramasser des déchets
tout tout ce qui dit les Mo les
bouteilles en plastique les bouteilles
en vert
[Musique]
ben en fait qu aujourd'hui ma mission en
fait que c'est pour que les gens
respectent un peu plus la nature et que
Z mettent pas déchet par terre que à
chaque instant quand ça piqunique et
tout ça là ben de de ramener un chachet
poubelle exote et de ramener chez vous
et de mettre dans les poubelles de chez
chez vous en fin de compte de emmener
une bouteille plastique pour mettre leur
Mo de cigarette dedans pour que la pour
que la nature reste propre en fin de
compte parce que la nature c'est un truc
qui respire les est comme nous et il
demande beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]
d'attention cette action qui a l' sport
plaisir et citoyenneté et un petit peu
ce qu'on veut faire passer le message
qu'elles veulent faire passer et que
nous on veut donner aussi aux gens c'est
qu'on vit à la Réunion on est sur une
petite île il faut prendre soin de notre
environnement et et il faut mettre la
main ensemble et ça passera forcément
par par cette génération là et les
enfants à venir c'est pour montrer au C
gens que ben c'est un espace c'est un
joli paysage que faudrait
respecter cet environnement c'est c'est
notre île quoi en gros c'est pour nous
c'est pour tout le
[Musique]
monde